deux
[Musique]
un de tes suicides
ma mère comme une blague
boniface pour ta chance
[Musique]
pour idiot
et je lui ai donné
et c'était comme ça
[Musique]
je
un doux et même dire
fallait dire
[Musique]
la vie et pour ta femme
je m'entends bien
[Musique]
et c'était comme ça
Oui
et facile
Oui oui
Oui
[Musique]
et ce sujet
je suis tombé à l'intérieur
[Musique]
m de goya
mon avis si tout
[Musique]
les poissons sont bons
dans un bato llosa ne jamais forcer
il y a un terrain de foot
oui sur facebook même si la vie vaut plus
couverture facile
oui facile
[Musique]
Oui oui
c'est facile
moi, j'étais
Tu pleures
[Musique]
oui oui oui ça va
où j'ai fait
et
Oui oui
Où l'obtiens-tu
[Musique]
Oui
et facile
peu ailleurs
que je
[Musique]
il m'a déjà dit
c'est facile oui oui
si tu
Alors
[Musique]